que changeriez-vous dans votre vie si
vous aviez un Magic Touch
la seule chose que je veux savoir sur vous,
c'est comment vous sentez-vous chaque matin
quand vous vous voyez dans le miroir
[Applaudissements]
super
je comprends que tu aimerais  ressembler
à Anthony Quinn dans cozumido à Notre
Dame mais je veux dire si vous aviez le choix
qui aimeriez-vous ressembler à
l'amant de ma mère que changeriez-vous dans
votre vie si vous aviez un Magic Touch
cuit
et il y a toutes sortes de choses que les
hommes  Je veux en savoir plus sur les
cicatrices, celle-ci en particulier
que vous avez sur le visage est-ce un piège
pour les femmes ou est-ce juste que vous
essayez de dire des conneries aux hommes non seulement en
ouvrant la bouche alors qu'elle aurait dû
être fermée
il y a des choses qui  Je dois être d'accord
avec vous sur l'une des choses, c'est que
vous avez dit
que tout est une relation sexuelle
avec les femmes. Je suppose que c'est un piège.
La
réparation  ne parlez pas de leur impolitesse pourquoi
pensiez-vous que
c'était parce que vous avez été allaité que
vous avez ce truc à propos des
seins non c'est parce que j'aime tellement les seins que
votre oncle a dirigé Le troisième homme
qu'il a été fait chevalier
était-ce j'espère que
c'était ça  Je vais vous dire directement si
c'était utile qu'il ait été réalisateur
d'un film oscarisé,
plusieurs d'entre eux bien sûr quelle réponse rapide
euh c'est un peu comme demander euh
[Musique]
le gagnant de l'Arctic Trio
s'il est élevé  eh bien, s'il est un dissident, il y a de fortes
chances que si vous mettez un sprinter à un
sprinter,
vous sortirez en tant que
sprinter et Wing the art Trio êtes-vous
fier d'être une Adele
dans le film
totalement nu avec Alan mates
Daniel Jackson qu'est-ce que c'était
[Musique]
est-ce que ça vous rend nerveux
que quelqu'un comme Ken Russell vous ait
nommé réalisateur
ou vous
dites simplement que c'est un travail
[Musique]
comment s'est passée votre expérience avec Terry
Gilliam à Munchausen et je
comprends
que vous étiez formidable dedans c'était
merveilleux pour e  La première fois de ma vie,
j'ai été autorisé à jouer quelque chose de
sérieux
euh pensez-vous que l'alcool était bon
ou mauvais d'accord
[Musique]
très bien je pense que c'est un très bon
charisme pour tout le monde je n'ai jamais vu
personne y compris
qui n'a pas fonctionné  bien avec une sorte
de stimuli
et si ça va être une femme avec de gros
seins ou une femme avec de longues jambes ou une
femme avec une boîte à fées ou une
maison
si votre vie était je suppose
dans la vie de tout le monde il y a une nécessité
mais si c'était  va être vécu à nouveau
le quitterais-tu encore Je serai ma
grand-mère et il a été fait chevalier Je suppose que nous
avons tous des doutes sur nous-mêmes oh
mais si tu avais le choix en
qui te changerais-tu avant
[Musique]